breakers thanks Samsung thanks for
thanks to the organizers for kindly
giving me the opportunity to talk about
these I included the subtitle which is
quantum and on synchrony graph
isomorphism to be a little bit more
information so this is work that has
been done together with Alberta's areas
from Universitat politècnica de
Catalunya government syska from
University of Bristol David Roberts on
my colleague at UCL Robert Sherman from
Short University in Prague and Antonius
bar with Shorty's from Nanyang
Technological University and Centre for
patent technology it's in the port so
part of this work has been done actually
here while other was and while Robert we
stepped very short depth of the contact
I will give some notions of isomorphism
specifically the types a lot about FISMA
would be interested on that are quantum
isomorphism and not serious morphism I
will give definitions of these notions
later I will talk about no longer games
I will tell what a perfect strategy for
a local game is and then I will say
something about all these different
notions relate to each other and I will
conclude with some very natural short
open problems
so other morphisms these are definitions
that are very familiar to this audience
given graph G and H they are zoomorphic
and life is denoted in this way if there
exist an N by n permutation matrix P
whose entries are di J such that the
following integer linear program is
physical we want two conditions
the first two that have to do with the
definition of reproduction matrix and
the last condition which I will
implement isomorphism what's perimeter
cymatics we we heard a lot about
computation in the last half an hour but
just to to fix the terminology these
indeed the matrix whose main valiantly
status even once and there is a unique
one and in every row the unique own
entry in the recall isomorphous was
implemented by the fact that remote
akamalik's commutes with the Justin C
matrices of the two graphs and just
recall John symmetric so a graph is a 0
1 matrix indexed by D the vertices of a
graph that is one opposition IJ is an
edge between backtick sign that is J is
here there is another definition of
fractional isomorphism present audience
so graph G and H are fractional and some
Arctic they not end in this way if there
is a Bobby stochastic matrix such that
the matrix s the stochastic communes
with the Giants matrices of the two
girls now a stochastic matrix is just
Melissa T's in the convex hull of the
set were nationalists or more direct
definition metric societies that are
non-negative real numbers between 0 & 1
such that the sum of the entries in each
row is 1 and some of them disavow this
one remark we know that two graphs are
fractional marthy given the leaf the
one-dimensional
by Solomon methods fake I I got it right
if someone
okay so in this definition of quantum
isomorphism which will be a central
topic in this talk now so now this is a
definition but it's not really efficient
because it turned out to be a theorem
but I said now as a definition to to to
give immediately a feeling about this
topic and easier to remember so this is
just a matrix relaxation of the integer
linear program which continues for graph
isomorphism so we replace the
permutation matrix with a block matrix P
these are the blocks and except by inj
each block is a complex orthogonal
projector these are just complex
matrices such that their ID important
and they are hermitian so it means that
P is equal to P transpose conjugate now
we have a program in our mission there
are boots
the define quantum isomorphism which is
denoted in this way yeah it is Q so
first of all we want this first
condition that tells me that I have
projectors then I would like that in
every row and every column of this block
matic so block and row of blocks and
column of blocks of mimetics they
resolved identity and then I would like
this relation here so if the transmat
extensor standard chronica product with
an identity matrix now the size of this
event the matrix is free so the it means
that the size of P is play is actually a
part of the problem so this is this can
be arbitrarily large now your are some
remarks if if the dimension of the
identity matrix is 1 then adjustable
permutation matrix so I simply have
standard graph isomorphism
notice that the large matrix black
matrix P is unitary meaning that P times
P adjoint is directly and
and third third the fact is that P is
something she's called Quantum Latin
square if each projector NJ is wrong one
and and this is a topic what is choir
introduced by Jenny Viking and master
and Jamie was here but unfortunately he
left and then as a four-three mark so
this definition as I said at the
beginning this light is actually a
theorem in this guy's an and later I
will motivate this definition by looking
at two non-local games there are no
local games so what is analog her games
so these are two party game which
includes a verifier and two players
Alice and Bob so Alice and Bob get
together and buy the strategy before the
game but when the game starts they can
not talk to each other so they are
physically separated if you like or that
could be extended if are for example one
in a galaxy in one another galaxy
the game is defined in terms of five
team put sets let's say XA and xB and
find out sets Y and y be and Allison Bob
will win receive from from the very fire
elements of XA + x2 + f2 some bacteria
fire elements of the sets why are you
awake and and the game is defined by
this boolean predicate on all these
product on sets and of course there is a
distribution only meaning the verify
will choose the inputs according to some
distribution
now this is indeed how the game works
and again the verifier samples a pair
from the input set using distribution
pipe and sample for one element to Alice
from Excel one element to be from it's
the very respond with elements from
their output set and we say that the
players win the game if the predicate is
one now an example of a perfect strategy
is just a definition terminology if the
way with probability one this is
definition on the lock again
no there are three let's say macroscopic
three special type of of strategies
classical strategies partner strategies
and non single strategies so now to
explain why there are these three
specific strategies one should take some
time because it would have to go to the
history of games and the background in
which this idea has been introduced
which is it's actually from physics and
in fact as a note here the last 50 years
of the study of the difference between
classical mechanics from mechanics is
mostly based on the study of no longer
games in a way or another and some
related ideas so now what is a classical
strategy
I just write these in words without
writing any mathematics but it will be
clear from the context that Iran so
Alice and Bob have classical resources
for example they've shared randomness
they could have strings or bits are in
their prime consists you of abandoned
and invested samples from some Corelli
distribution this is what we have in the
classical world in case strategies will
be strategies that Alice and Bob can
obtain when they can perform drawing
measurement on a shelf on to state and
again I will explain this in a minute
and then on signally strategies this is
small beyond party mechanics for the one
was that where you're at the boot camp
so without extensive discussion about
this topic and
they tell us all of these lectures so
what is not singly simply means that L
is large block of marginal distributions
are independent of Bob choice on Raymond
ambassadors so in other words Eddie's
cannot obtain any information about Bob
inputs based on there are or over input
and output ambassadors so really they
cannot talk to each other they cannot
learn from about what they do locally
what our players and here is the the
game this no Locker game which will
allow me to define this notion of
Panama's overseas so the verifier sends
a listen Bob vertices of two graphs so
here is the Union onset of words of two
graphs shows a uniformly at random so
now they respond with two vertices again
from these two graphs but there are two
conditions that must be satisfied in
order for anything Bob to win so if L is
with your vertex from from one graph she
must respond with a vertex of the other
graph ambassadors Bob is here at least
one graph let's say from gee you must
display a graph from H for bata bata
players and then the second condition
here I do not read XA xB equal well why
be the relation between XA and xB what
is it so that they if L is embalm she
vertices that are adjacent in a graph
they must send backward are adjacent in
the other graph listen if the receiver
state are non-adjacent in the graph the
muscle back ratchet emerges in the graph
there is it the same vertex they must
send back the same darkness this is the
conditions that are in order for the
players to win the game so now here is
that the remark which is if you play
this game for G and H or for the
compliments graph compliments on G and H
the game is the same can we make it more
casual
so now for what I see there's no
apparent connection with particular
games and third remark is that somehow
this is a devolution of more rudimentary
non-local games for constraint
satisfaction problems that have been out
there for a while one of those is called
monochromatic number there's a reference
in the mister reference and and then
part 2 morphism induced by by Robertson
specific Agility's and by Robertson man
Cisco very illicit and indeed somehow
this this talk is is a contraction of
their work and an extension of the work
done by Robertson imagines this is the
definition of cheap H isomorphism game
which will allow me to introduce the
notion of quantum isomers so here is the
contribution of this talk now for two
graphs J and H we are deformed first
there is a perfect classical strategy
for the G H as a morphism game
adjustability in this way if and only if
agenda insurance market there is a
perfect part to strategy for the G H as
a morphism game even a leaf G and H are
quantum azimuth meaning there exists
such a block matrix that will give me
that relation between the graphs in the
distant third there is a perfect not
even astonishing which I will explain
what what what consists of even the leaf
the graphs are fractional as a model and
then I will show that these reductions
are in fact different meaning that graph
isomorphism implies part of our feyza
which implies fractures are more
feasible but known of these holding
deliver out mean that there are
fractional samosa graphs are not
partners a morphic another part much
more suggest
so and yeah I described they started for
plaintively I have to tell you the
notional correlation so given a fixed
strategy a correlation we find simply
for as this joint conditional
probability
what is it simply the probability that
the Telus Bob output
why why do you want the receive XA and
xB in the in the gh as a morphism game
we have data collection pickles
pokerface strategy if and only if this
is 0 whenever the wind conditions wanted
to do which I described before fail now
depending on the type of correlation
which are introduced that will be given
by the type of physics I'm using which
is classified mechanics quantum
mechanics for this a known non natural
physics which have not seen any
correlations then I will have different
twenty-first energy so here is perfect
classical strategies and and the first
portion of the results of this work
there's a perfect classic I studied you
for the graph for G H as a revision gave
in the leaf to Jesus or morphic to H and
sketch for the proof which is very very
minimal this is I just follow just on
one way is absolutely straightforward
because by the game small and it's a
bobcat together they find an isomorphism
photograph they write it down on a piece
of paper they go away definitely as if I
asked them questions and they answer
back by just looking at the picture that
they draw
one side is straightforward the left
side suppose we have shared randomness
in any case we can restrict our
knowledge to the domestic strategies I
won't go through that but it's very
simple to see and we end up with a pair
of functions F and F be on the on the
union of the set of words from the two
blasts into the satellites of the two
graphs and then one can show that this
function turned out to be the same for
any symbol and this is useful because
then we can restrict ourself to two
specific sort of person I am sure that
the dysfunction are nothing but
isomorphisms so meaning that if you play
this game with resources that come from
classical mechanics then we end up to a
standard graph isomorphism okay now in
order to talk about quantum strategies I
will need to tell you a little bit about
the the mathematical backgrounds that we
can use the mathematical tools we can
use for this which is the forming so we
have Android system and quantum system
simplest led to sound to some vector
space semilla space of dimensions so a
state which is a picture of the system
at a certain time is just a vector of
normal one in this complex space and
there's something called P of e m+
operator valid measurement which is
simply a family of positive
semi-definite matrices such that there
is of the identity so the sum of this
matrix is equal to the identity matrix
so suppose that we have a system in a
certain state so what is the probability
of the outcome when we measure the state
with respect to this period it's simply
this expression vector times the matrix
times the adjoint of the vector and we
have a special case which is projective
measurements where these position
diplomatic say Rank 1 and they are
portable projectors
now since we are arriving again here
with two players I will have to consider
our system that has two parts so quantum
system which is composed by two spaces
see the one see the two respectively of
dimension D 1 and D 2 and the joint
state would be simply a vector in this
larger system larger space now there is
a notion of in tanga state simple event
under state here in our context is just
a vector that cannot be written as a
chronica product of two vectors one in
one one one system and one in the other
system and a joint measurement simply
will correspond to having a chronica
product of two of these poly silicon
matrices corresponding to two perhaps
which one would be retirees and what
would really pop and now what is the
heart of such under study simply
consists of a state and for each for
each vertex X in the union of the
vertices of G whenever so H there will
be a set of pure VMs for Alice which are
index at PI which I listen in this way
and the set of Chileans for BOM that
ring except in this way just two sets of
matrices one with with one player and
one with other player so what they will
do in order to play the game that we
received from the reviewer their
vertices they can apply their mattresses
on this disjoint vector state and the
hand see what they get and they will
somehow use what they got in order to to
play now the prodigal is default in fact
L is receive XA and performs a
measurement e XP and obtain y ay
pobrecito XP a preferred measure
f XP end of the and obtain some white so
what's the Contra correlation probably
some Bob output in vertices why am i we
upon receiving excellent XP and this is
simply given by this conditional
probability which is just these
operators
a product here applied on the vector and
yeah I'm sorry I changed notation
because I want to find this light and
then didn't notice that I left this
dagger here is that then they start but
this is the adjoint okay what special
status as before the Festa is one you
obtained this whenever the condition
wanting to of the agenda with the final
thing okay so what about definite signal
mister dishes now we will be on part two
mechanics the probability tell him about
wood does not depend on board sorry
provided events respectively borne out
does not run the water specialized input
this is simply described by respect but
just define the specific correlation his
context is constant for every for every
input let Bob three ships now if L is a
simple Excel and Bob she protects meet
Robert Ellis out it obtains output while
a worshiper first measurement is just
remark or part operation Cerner's not
see Gurley mean that somewhat mechanics
is a subset of this larger world of
correlation maximum correlations but the
converse is not necessary to in fact
there are some kind of maybe no physical
object which is called usually focus
Quranic box such that the verifier
center to be a and B to the players and
and players need to send back x and y
and then in this box the XOR of the
input is always equal to the end of the
output something we cannot do
classically because if you look at the
truth table on this tool then they
consult in three cases
would assume that points i bobby's and
from this small it follows that graph
isomorphism by this pattern isomorphism
that implies here is the proof of
mitered the result which is R is a
perfect natural strategy for the GH as a
physical game and I live the graphs are
fractional isomorphic the proof on one
side is basically not algebra on the
other side uses a result of ramana
Shannon Mullen Wolman stating that two
graphs a fraction as a morphic and all
if they have a common equitable
partition fortunately I don't have much
time to go to trudys but I will leave
the slide so in case
okay so now what you like to prove and
this is again
she was like very quickly is that
fractionalized or more fizzle does not
imply quantum isomorphism this is very
simple why because I had this unitary
matrix the relation for the much more
efficient and turns out that if you
refer to my zoomorphic than there are Co
Specter and they they complement circus
doctor but we know that there are
fractions Marsha graphs that are not Co
spectrally so we have this let me go in
the end
today to the last part which is that
part was over feasible does not imply
isomorphism and the other will have to
introduce a little bit of notions so
what is a linear binary constraint
system game which I which I operate as
BCS so this is a family of linear
equations or over left there is an
example I will be 69 equations 0 0 0 0 0
and the last one here is 1 now how does
the game go Ellis is given a constraint
which is any question that says he I
with a set of variable s I so she must
assign values to the variable in C I so
that this is satisfied and Bob does the
same with our constraint let's say CJ so
say Bob must be consistent on variable
shared by CI n CJ so these are the sets
of variables for these two constraints
so when asked the same quest and of
course they must give the same
assignment now notice that this is
slightly different from the standard
formulation of what has been studied
usually in the literature in popularity
because usually there Alice receive a
constraint and publish a variable and
then
forest ranger and bombers to
surveillance so classical player can win
a linear burn requesting gaming probably
one if not if the battery cost States
history satisfiable right that's but in
the part two case what we do we relax it
is as we have done before in a way so we
replace the zeros and ones
first of all with plastic - what I wants
to be be consistent we were her gonna do
next it's a simple it is the following
what our satisfy something cimento
projectors okay as a scenario to the
variable sex is such that each Christine
satisfied and project the same cosine
community so meaning that for for this
constrain we replace the variables with
matrices here and and this will be just
added identity matrix or minus the
identity matrix and there is this
theorem which is recent by little which
is a bar across state system game as a
perfect contrast ology from the leaf the
corresponding Berenstain system is part
unsatisfiable and this is actually
interesting topic which is created small
new direction surge
discrete rallies which interplay between
operators Tyrian combinatorics here is
an example of one of these games that is
classically I did the discussed a known
satisfy ball but is quite unsatisfiable
she called usually mummy Paris Magic
Square and effect correspond exactly to
these constraints this one with the two
bars is the one that correspond to the
okay and now what we do in order to look
back at our GHS a more physical game we
consider the finally by our constraint
system just as an example
yeah I'll go start a graph so this graph
is actually based on our constructor by
by five and very simple so so for each
constraint CL and Simon after that
satisfy CL add other vertex liability in
this way and there will be an edge
between two such vertices if there is
there exists some variable in the
intersection of them parables for the to
restrain such that they need to be and
that's the graph associated to this
specific example so now for any linear
very constrained system if I do not buy
f0y homogeneous version of f
simply means that every equation now
it's gonna be equal zero so if one
before was opposed to one I just remove
the one and says he wants you so and
these of course is always classic I said
his father right so it's always classic
Alisa so here is it here which says that
for any linear manner restraint system f
the fawley node so Fe satisfy belief in
belief this graph that I can start to GF
is as a market with the graph G 0 and
also f the Spartan satisfy belief in the
leaf the graph G F is quantum isomorphic
to the graph G at 0 and the crawler is
default the exists graph G and H such
that G is known as a morphic to H but G
is quantum a small fee to H it
particularly if F is a linear Ballack
restraint system at this point satisfied
well not satisfiable then the graph
corresponding to F is known as a morphic
to the graph correspond to 0 but the
graph as a morphic to F is quantum as
more photographs correspond with you and
yes and this actually tells me that
cartomizer more fish mr. Dufresne or
something
of course there are paragraphs for which
this is the case and I could use this
specific system as an example I think
he's on 23 their societies I think yeah
that's yeah that's it yeah we have
discussed with her and threw some grass
but a lot against was elected of a class
or more fizzle but is motivated by the
local games and turns out to be
obtainable by playing games with an odd
signal in correlations and the other one
is customers more feature that to me
looks and so open problems of courses
interracial complexity of this with
logic and all the rest let's say you're
mean to set the separating example was a
family resemblance to the settlement
construction so my question is obviously
this is quantum isomorphism does it sit
somewhere in the boys file already been
hierarchy I think
is there a notion of quantum fractional
isomorphism where you take convex
combinations of the projectors or is
that or that's out just coincide
I don't see how would you play it in a
game you sure yeah so in such case I'm
not sure how would you play because you
can of course me to have purely a mess
oh that's time capsule